[Music]
hi everyone my name is nari Seoul and
today we're going to go over some ways
to sound like Claude Debussy now of
course it goes without saying that to
cover the details of his genius in a
video like this is pretty absurd but
here just a few practical ways that help
me understand his music and also allow
me to imitate at least the surface layer
of his style let's first take the melody
and add more space around the notes to
create an atmospheric vibe
[Music]
next let's add in our pated harp light
cascades accompanied with a resonant
bass line that often accentuates a
perfect fifth at the bottom linger on
tonal centers and generally avoid using
functional cadences
[Music]
an example of this is to use cores with
tritones in them such as dominant chords
without resolving them
[Music]
make use of Tremeloes to add tension
[Music]
include a lot of rhythmic variation in a
fluid manner
and also use spaced-out syncopated lines
to have an ambiguous sense of pulse at
times
[Music]
move chords and gestures with parallel
movement
[Music]
you scale such as the whole tone and
pentatonic scales as well as different
types of modes
[Music]
also include bell-like rings that add to
the atmosphere of the music
[Music]
and last but not least used textures and
Tambor's that create an air of ambience
and an imaginative mood
[Music]
and without further ado here's happy
birthday in the style of called Debussy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I hope you enjoy that thanks so much
for watching and if you're interested in
the PDF of this version of happy
birthday it'll be available on my
website where you can also find my book
of modified Chopin exercises and other
sheet music anyway thanks again and I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
you
[Music]